good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy
monday mondays should be dreary but they
ain't because today
we are celebrating our 700th episode of
the morning toast which is
quite nuts honestly quite nuts and by
the way i'm here too
oh yeah hey everyone um i'm back i
missed you all so much so excited to be
back on the toast so excited for our
700th
episode we have obviously done so many
episodes but we really don't celebrate
our big milestones
no and i don't know just like 700 felt
different it's
so many episodes really i feel like
we've done more
really yeah no like in a year-ish we'll
be at a thousand
like we should be at a thousand yeah
pinning we don't get canceled
um we should be at a thousand now i feel
like we've literally done so many we've
done so many
but we've done 700 and that's a lot of
episodes yeah
okay no it's a ton i'm feeling super
proud i'm also i'm mostly proud that
we've done 700 episodes and we still
have stuff to talk about and the show is
still good funny
better than ever no more relevant than
ever funnier than ever
charting than ever like yeah sickening
than ever
no i agree like honestly the fact that
and of course some episodes are more
full than others but there's never
really been a day where we truly have
nothing to talk about even when there is
nothing to talk about in the world and
sometimes like having nothing to talk
about
it's so funny it's something to talk
about no we have made having nothing to
talk about into a full segment
mindlessness
a hundred percent so the creativity
knows no bounds
but today's episode is not mindless
because we have so much to catch up on
like obviously the news of the weekend
the last week i wasn't here missed you
all so dearly i was on friday's episode
and we did do a patreon so i do feel a
little caught up and up to speed
but i just feel like i have so much
making up to do no it's
it's been a journey here without you and
we're so i think i speak on behalf of
everyone
we're so thrilled and relieved to have
you back okay
i have two confirmed what about you yep
yeah okay everyone's happy thank god
no actually you should have heard what
they were saying about you like the ice
queen oh my god it was finally like
partying yeah i could all finally talk
[ __ ] about you
like teacher's gone like we could live
it up at yes at the toe studio no sure
sure yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
yeah tyler scenes yeah tyler she was
talking the most [ __ ] about you
yeah i sensed that from him no also can
we talk about did you listen to his
episode yet
no oh my god okay okay i have been
booked and busy and i landed last night
i got home
at midnight and i just i was so busy and
then
okay whatever i had no time let me just
tell you i was like giving him like a
whole debrief i brought up luanne or
something and i
he was like who is luanne and i went on
this whole like magilla teaching him
about housewives the historical
importance of the suez canal
et cetera et cetera he got booked on
what happens live this week with luanne
stop so he should i was expecting a text
like thank you for the brief history
lesson
that is so funny you should text him and
be like good thing you're all
brief well i texted we have the same
agent which is how he came on the show
and i texted her i was like
not tyler being on what happens live
with luanne she was like oh my god i was
dying
that's so so funny yeah so um that's
just me helping other people get ahead
and it's what i really love to do
yeah and you're so good at it and i'm
not bitter at all
no it's gonna be good that'll be good
content yeah yeah and i am so behind on
tv but we are gonna get back to tv
recaps this week just for me starting
tomorrow if that's fine well there is no
tv tomorrow but yeah starting this week
like when oh
yeah so tuesday wednesday thursday
friday we will get caught up on love
island beverly hills potomac
um i didn't watch potomac last night
because the olympics were on and i don't
know if anyone noticed
but i'm wearing my most proud american
outfit my red hoops my blue romper and
my
red white and blue uh asos uh
what are these called bomber jackets so
i don't know just don't come for me
proud american over here
you're feeling like proud in the
olympics i don't know if i'm like
feeling proud because i was watching a
lot last night like we didn't win that
many medals but then that guy steve
you know steve do you know who i'm
talking about
the guy with the board do you know oh
from cnn i think they're using him again
for the olympics with like his special
board because he gave this whole
presentation
and like i guess i i think i'm reminded
of this every year
we're like the best yeah like win the
olympics it's weird like depending on
the headlines that you read like i read
a headline that we
the usa had the worst first day in
olympics like since 1972. well that's
possible because i watched and it didn't
feel great
i also read a headline today that the us
swimming team has won more first medals
in their first day than ever before
well so it's like is it the best or is
it the worst yeah i think we're winning
a lot of medals but like
i don't know if they're gold you know
medals are medals sorry
i agree either right you get to chomp
down on it
would you rather this is like a dumb
question but i've actually thought about
this a lot
would you rather have a silver or a
bronze
i i think i asked because it looks more
like gold yes and i tell your friend
came into my house they would just say
assume it's gold you know i'm not going
to hang up a bronze
yeah yeah so and they look really
similar so i was actually thinking like
silver is so second place bronze is like
kind of ambivalent
it's him that's the word i was looking
for yeah ambivalent that's
funny ambivalent means neutral neither
here nor there
ambiguous is like confusing yes i meant
ambiguous and i know the difference i'm
sorry that was just like brain fart
monday
um so yeah that's what i was watching
last night even though like shots of
sunset was on behalf of
potomac it's so hard i was watching
olympics all weekend like and i did not
watch anything else what did i say to
everyone like when the olympics starts
i'm wearing this album for the next two
weeks like
i'm so invested so the tv recaps like
might have to take a backseat because
i'm busy being a proud american over
here i think that's fine you know like
it's once in a lifetime aka every four
years like it's
a it is and also there's another
olympics in six months which is crazy i
[ __ ] love the olympics you know they
added cheerleading as a sport
i was wondering where cheerleading was
well because that's why when we watched
um
cheer on netflix why was so popular was
because it really sucks as an athlete in
college
like you put your whole life into
gymnastics i mean into cheerleading
and at the end of college that's it
there's no professional career for a
cheerleader which just kind of sucks
so now i think it's an official you
could do like nfl or nba but oh yeah but
what you're doing at the competitive
level is is actually like
more competitive right so i don't know
it's
definitely not this olympics but moving
forward and i couldn't help but think
like is gabby butler going to be on the
american olympic team
she should be but the only thing to me
that i think might prove to be
challenging for the
cheerleaders people cheering
cheerleaders
is that like they're all individual
athletes and they're gonna have to come
together and learn a routine
you know if you're a professional
cheerleader that's what you do right but
like
everyone else pretty much performs as
individuals the only team
is basketball which like still you no
synchronized swimming they perform a
dance together
but it's two people they also have like
a six group but they're like lifelong
partner like they compete together so i
think peop
cheerleaders or either individual
cheerleaders will qualify for the
olympics and then monica will get in
there and give them a routine
monica better be a part of the crow or a
whole
team qualifies for the olympics in which
case they have that connection
in which case the team from cheer what
are they called navarro
bulldogs navarro cheers dogs tomorrow
dogs um no that's a good point i don't
know how it's going to work but i'm very
much looking forward to it i'm assuming
it's going to be a summer sport yes
yeah because they do it outside daytona
super summery
um i'm just really concerned about like
everyone learning the choreography in
time and also like
qualifying well i'm really concerned
that like it's not going to be for
another four years and it's gabby butler
still going to be in fighting shape
because in
the documentary cheer on netflix they
said she is the most
famous and most talented gymnast slash
cheerleader
not gymnast cheerleader in america there
four she would be on the team correct
yeah but by the way it's three years now
so
i guess i feel like she could she could
still do it yeah she's young
like i'm really holding out hopefully
that'd be so amazing like a great
way to end the story arc that we started
and cheer on netflix yeah
i i'm glad for the cheerleaders i was
actually thinking like this could be an
olympic sport because you know they're
always adding olympic sports
skateboarding
yes and we could talk about that because
i did watch yesterday
and like of course you know nobody's
perfect and who am i you know big fat
slob on my couch to judge
you people fall in gymnastics every now
and then with skateboarding it was like
every single person like fall fall
fall yeah you know what i was thinking
about like i just was feeling badly
for um ethan hawk because
tony hawk tony hawk i was like i think
ethan hockey is the guy from the
terrible movie but um
it just felt right tony i was feeling
badly for tony hawk
such an amazing celebrated skateboarder
like lifelong skateboarder
career storied skateboarder and like now
it's an olympic sport
i mean he didn't get to be an olympian
this whole time i mean i really don't
feel bad for him because he's like
crying you know wiping his tears with
billion dollars he's literally so
[ __ ] rich i'm
so sad i'm so worried about him oh um
literally what's the opposite of worried
i'm so i'm sleeping peacefully knowing
tony hawk is
fine no and so you know what so is ethan
hawk
i i'm sure he's fine but i'm sure that's
a little bit of a bummer
like like i guess he was an olympic
level skateboarder and he never got to
compete at the olympics no but he got to
become
something arguably better like rich and
famous i know he could have been on the
cover of wheaties
box i'm sure he has been i don't know
i'm sure like all of his friends who
were athletes were like but were
olympians and he's like but i'm an
athlete too bro
and like during the two weeks when all
of his friends like went to tokyo he
like sat at home alone like watching on
instagram right like trying to convince
everyone he was an athlete yeah it's
like yeah sure tony
sure tony so anyways that's what i was
thinking no that's an interesting
thought so i'm just like having the best
time like i'm literally gonna go home
and like i subscribe to like olympic
channel
peacock because the prime time thing
ended before the skateboarding last
night and i was like where i needed my
fix
so i got on peacock i got the nbc sports
app and there's just so much content
and also justice for beach volleyball
like it's literally the best part i saw
your story
it's so good like what athleticism and
they have to walk around in underwear
yeah it's the craziest thing yeah
justice for them well actually there's a
lot of drama now did you see
some bikini bottoms norwegian um i don't
know if it's beach or indoor volleyball
they refuse to wear the underwear
they're like we want to wear shorts but
it's not
regulation and they got fined and our
girl pink
offered to pay the fine that's so funny
because i read the headline
and it was really misleading because it
said that they refused to wear the
bikini bottom so
i thought they just wanted to like be
naked
and they were going to get fined for
that but to get courses we could find
for that but forget
to get fined for wanting to wear just
longer shorts because they're not
regulation
it's so stupid it's crazy and so pink is
out here
supporting the norwegian volleyball
players we love to see it
she's such an icon and a queen a little
bit of a content update from me that i'm
hoping
praying that you're gonna find
interesting um because a few weeks ago
on the show we were talking about the
titanic and i said that i was going to
read
more about the titanic yeah and so i'm
almost done with this book about the
titanic like right now they just were um
they were rescued by the ship so i think
it's going to be a lot about like the
repercussions
um but i i've learned a lot of
interesting factoids about the titanic
and
one that i think you would like to know
is that in reality
they did not lock third class passengers
intentionally in like those
doors like in the movie that did not
happen and also well they didn't do it
intentionally or they didn't do it at
all they didn't do it at all there was
one there was one gate that was locked
because it was night time and they
locked the gates and also there
i learned that everything like the
classes were really separate because of
u.s
quarantine rules for immigrants so like
they actually couldn't interact
at all during the during the trip um
there was one gate that was locked
because it was nighttime but you could
hop over it
but there were also other gates right
and then also you know the scene that
scene is horrible i know and you know
the scene where they're
like the people in the boiler room are
like running under before each like door
closes yeah
there was no like injuries in that way
okay and how do they know that like the
survivors
yeah this is gonna be a really dumb
question like maybe the dumbest one i've
ever asked
because i don't really know like when
the titanic was are any of the titanic
survivors still alive
i was thinking that no it was in 1912 so
even if you were
a newborn baby one you wouldn't remember
anything and two you'd be like a hundred
and
yeah yeah yeah okay okay yeah not touch
i mean it's still possible
yeah but it's not like it's probably not
possible okay yeah well that is
interesting thank you that you know that
does
like ease my nerves a little bit i can't
watch that movie like it's so terrible
yeah tragedy travesty so the book i'm
reading is called ship of dreams and
it's a little
dense and i would just say you know
watch the movie totally yeah they're
dramatized for a reason it's good
yeah yeah no for sure but it is cool to
like i've been highlighting some
interesting factoids so maybe if
people are interested when i'm done with
the book i could read some of the facts
that i've learned
sure just like i promised that i would
you know i just want people to know i'm
delivering
you're delivering such a delivery woman
thank you thank you um before we type in
i think let's
let's take a moment look at our our 700
episodes as a whole
okay let's talk about it okay i don't
really have an end to this question well
i thought you were gonna say what's your
favorite episode
it's that's like choosing a favorite
child it's obviously theo but you know
what i mean
yeah i don't think i can choose a
favorite episode but what was your
favorite
era so far like we've had a lot of
studios oh
um i would say my definitely like my
least favorite era was
the previous one the previous studio um
in
where we got evicted okay that was just
like a bad time it was where we were
quarantined
i didn't love that studio like i just i
don't have good positive associations
with that time i think that was like 20
like
early 2020 yeah didn't like that okay
and i would say
i think my favorite era was our original
studio even though it was far and like
it was ugly
it was just like we had such low
expectations for ourselves yeah and i
loved it
yeah i think my favorite era was not
like early days of that first studio but
like eventually we like got really
snatched
on a personal and professional level and
um those were some good times we had
like snitch cam going yeah when snitch
was with us those were good times
yeah so those were fun times but i also
like love this era me too
also i love all of our halloween
episodes yeah like there hasn't been one
i did not like
no they're actually it's hard to pick a
favorite i know and i think like of
course i think the og is gonna always be
my favorite because it was so funny when
we dressed up as each other
but like i really but then i'm like oh
no but wait what about the kardashians
like margot on the chris cam like yeah
there were
our most recent one was the best i think
for me the royal family is the best
it's so good yeah but also the jonas
brothers so good
and that was a hard day like our studio
was under construction we had to move to
like a makeshift studio yeah snitch was
sick it was so hot margaret had strep
throat yeah
and it was just still came through
because that's what kevin would do wwkd
what would kevin do and he would come
through yeah so i think those are
definitely like my top
we have to start planning like october
is almost upon us
i know but you know us it always comes
together last minute day before
yeah we planned for so long but we can't
come up with it until the day before and
you know we've actually had in the last
700 episodes but also recently like a
lot of amazing guests
chelsea handler like so famous we've had
some amazing guests we should count how
many guests we've had we probably had
like a hundred
well also do you count guests we had on
like a red carpet show
yeah okay not in real who do you think
is the most famous person we've ever had
on the show
it's so we had like back to back in the
same week the two most famous people
we've had kevin o'leary uh-huh and
chelsea emma on the same week
yeah it's hard for me to say because i
can't think
of all the guests right now yeah and i
guess like if i do include red carpet
like luke holmes is up there too
yeah no there's just there's so many so
many memories
and i've just been fabulous doing it all
alongside you you as well
keeping us keeping us you're like the
captain of the titanic but we will not
sink
captain smith no we hit an iceberg many
a time
many an iceberg many an iceberg but
jackie the captain doesn't let it
steer you know they said the titanic was
the unsinkable ship
they never met us they never meant to
toast did they say that
yeah that is the dumbest thing that's
like the biggest jinx of all time i know
but like at the time there were so many
ships being the unburnable forest it
wasn't like it wasn't like the first
ship ever and they were like this is
unsinkable like there were so many in
the same like
family of ships there were ships from
other companies and so the titanic was
like
the newest and not even biggest it
actually wasn't remarkable in any
real way other than the fact that it
sunk and if it hadn't sunk it wouldn't
have really broken any records but
that's pretty remarkable
right but like you never would have
heard of titanic no i didn't think no
but honestly whoever gave it that name
was not jewish because it's such a
kaninahara like so superstitious you
cannot say the unsinkable ship right
before you get on a ship
right but they didn't like it was just
people would say it you know people are
morons
no beyond be young and you know what
that's cool to know like because i look
around our world i'm like damn everyone
is moronic
but they were moronic in 1912 too and
that does bring me some solace
yeah also what i found to be crazy in
this book that i read was apparently
like 10 years before the titanic song
a fictional writer wrote like a novella
wasn't a book that was very popular
then um called called
something sad and it was about a ship
called the titan that hid an iceberg and
sunk
well do you remember like when kobe
first started that's what i was thinking
about yeah
yeah it was like something went viral
like somebody found this like old
chinese book of proverbs was it
confucius
no no whatever you just didn't say no
but it was like in the year 2021 a
virus rhona like it was so bizarre yeah
no
it was um there was a few things that
that
started circulating but one of them was
from a fictional book
where there was a infectious disease
that started in wuhan because there is a
laboratory there and so they just but
then that turned out to be
what happened interesting and then also
that fictional thing said
it disappeared as fast as it appeared
and then how that was
that was a different thing that was like
um some sort of omen it wasn't confucius
but it was it was a confucius vibe it
was a community to see vibe
yeah like i agree it was like you know
how there are some people in the world
i can only think of one that i read
about on daily mail who like correctly
predict like
yes like elections and like hundreds of
major events and so and so there'll be a
big thing in like
we need to find some of these i can't
explain it's like nostradamus
yeah no but people were just like
sending around all these spooky memes
like during coven and i don't know if
any of them were true
but confucius definitely got in there
yeah and i'm still waiting for it
disappears as quickly as it comes
yeah no that part um they definitely got
wrong the whole thing here we are
um we'll be a great show for you guys
today we do we have a lot to catch up on
a lot happen over the weekend let's just
do it
without further ado to do if you're
wondering where he is he said he
does not support the 700 episode that's
what he said that's pretty much
plain and simple he said i'll see you
for 701 yeah 100
we should just get like new balloons
every day 702
703 because we only get one new balloon
every day these are expensive though
balloons is the biggest crock of [ __ ]
like as an industry it's literal plastic
guess how much these balloons cost three
balloons
duh
two hundred dollars all right relax a
hundred dollars but still like
it's plastic and they're gonna be
literally on the floor in an hour these
ones do tend to last a while hopefully
we can save the two zeros for 800.
oh yes we'll store them in the closet
that'll be funny if this building is
just turned into a calendar of what
episode it is
no i'm telling you it's actually a good
idea it is a good idea you should just
get like a clock
like a ticker yeah it's like zero days
without incidents
right like 700 episodes without
cancellation
well no it's probably like 100 since
without cancellation
if we're being honest you can't cancel
someone who doesn't care
so without further ado to do it is time
yeah yeah sorry got sidetracked it is
time for the fast five stories that you
do need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
you do it's confirmed that you do need
to know that
um and today's epi i'm not even in the
mood to try
today's episode for 700. oh church oh
wait for 700.
i gotta do something big start again
okay without further ado without further
ado
where are you not here he doesn't
support us it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
i don't even know what i'm doing you
look like you're outside
well i was going to like pretend to have
a heart attack but that's like
insensitive even though our dad did die
to yourself yeah no literally and then i
was i don't like i don't know i'm
running out of ideas so i'll just dive
okay today's episode is brought to you
by honey
we all shop online and we've all seen
that promo code field
taunt us at checkout thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
because honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart they support over 30 000
stores online and they range from
websites that sell tech gaming products
makeup food delivery fashion brands
i pretty much think every single thing
on my body right now
i've bought online and got major
discounts with honey it's so like
there's literally no reason not to have
it it's free to download and it saves
you money
how it works is that you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites and when it's
time to check out
the honey button will drop down and all
you have to do is click apply coupons
wait a few seconds they'll search
literally the entire depths of the
internet to find you a discount
and if they find a working coupon you'll
watch the price drop automatically so
i've saved money on clothes
makeup literally everything i can think
of because i hate shopping in the stores
i have
trauma um they found over at 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings so there's literally no reason
for you not to have honey
if you don't already have it you are
missing out on free savings it is free
and it installs in just a few seconds go
to um joinhoney.com
toast to get honey for free that's join
joinhoney.com
toast to get um the browser extension
for free it'll change your life and you
don't have to spend
any money it's free i don't know if i
mentioned it's completely free get honey
for free oh yeah that's for for no money
right it doesn't what does honey cost
free oh wow zero more people should get
yeah
okay ready for our first story if it's
about ethan hawk
it is not about ethan hawk is ethan
hawking actor is it talking
no the stephen hawking ethan hawk old
man
kevin bacon hawk boyhood
yeah does he look like kevin bacon yeah
a little bit same vibe you're thinking
very personally yeah okay
you're warm yeah for sure okay i
remember when we were kids it's like
where is it you're getting warmer that
was so stupid
how was that just dumb speaking of
getting warmer
wow just cutting me off speaking of
getting warm and steamy
jlo celebrates her 52nd birthday by
kissing ben affleck
on a luxe yacht ben affleck did i say it
again yeah that was not intentional i
know sometimes you like do it on purpose
and i know it's a joke but you just like
very you said ben affleck
you know what let me live okay j.lo is
done hiding her rekindled romance with
ben affleck
after sharing photos of the pair
celebrating her 52nd birthday while
aboard a yacht in san tropez
exchanging a kiss she captioned it 5-2
what it do a collection of instagram
photos featuring shots of her in a print
bikini and a cover-up
the last of which find the actress
smooching ben
affleck and his hands are draped over
her shoulders no it was
a lot like first they put up their own
okay so here's what happened actually
leah remini ramini i don't know how to
pronounce it but i just died for her
had a birthday party and she put up a
little compilation video like very mom
on facebook it was like a video of
pictures you know
and she had a murmur photo booth at her
birthday dinner it was like a 50
dinner was fabulous like mini what it
was just stunning and
in her video montage there was a murmur
picture
of her jlo and ben and that was like the
first time and
i was watching daily pop on friday and
they were talking about like do you
think she got permission to share this
photo
and justin was like leah's been in the
business forever she's not going to like
blow up her best friend's bot so it was
definitely like an approved posting
by j.lo so that really opened the door a
little bit
then this yacht trip just blew the whole
thing wide open because not only
were they photographed like paparazzi
super clear photos grabbing the ass like
doing the most right
but then also content was put out on
jayla's personal instagram halo put
forth the content and said here we are
cementing the relationship
permanently and i just i never when we
spoke about this like a few weeks ago i
was like happy for like i just like
didn't really care
it wasn't doing that much for me but
these photos are doing the most for me
like ben affleck is hot again and i
think more people should be talking
about that because he went through like
a stage where he was just like not
doing it for me i i think he's a super
cutie
um i'm just really happy for j.lo it's i
guess i have to take back what i said
like i really thought they might be just
like business partners you know
venturing into something and
i think it's clear that they're
romantically linked i mean do you grab
your
business partner's house like that i
mean i i am your business partner so i
wish you would grab it if we were on the
yacht in san tropez
you would do it that's what i would be
doing for sure um
so yeah i guess these two are dating
yeah i guess it's pretty safe to say
that they're confirmed
yeah also and some like sad er news is
that a rod is also in san tropez like
just being thirst monster per usual
you know and his he's like on a bigger
yacht but it doesn't matter he's lonely
i don't care what yacht he's i'm also
like can you find some other
bay like go to nice you know like just
there's a million islands
a hunt go to greece but like everyone's
in san tropez right now you know
right but like he should really stay
away no it's honestly embarrassing for
him and i don't know if he's like
purposely like
i think the media has a lot to do with
like you know a-rods on his boat while
jlo and
you know and i don't know if he's like
necessarily following them around but
the way it's being depicted is
giving him such illusory vibes and he
needs like
he needs a major pr move because yeah
right now he's losing so hardcore like
not only did he disgrace arguably one of
the
hottest women on the planet and like one
of the most well respected as well
he's now losing in the aftermath of
their relationship like he hasn't been
linked to anyone
he's alone on his boat going down the
slide like yeah like with mystery girls
yeah yeah yeah so i just think he needs
help
i agree he needs to like just make
himself scarce and a little bit more
mysterious and
leave us wanting more yeah like i almost
feel bad for him you know because and so
this happens like most recently reminds
me of megan fox and brian
austin green he's in a better place now
but like when megan fox like
bounced out of brian austin green's
house and became like a part of this
insta obsessed couple it was like
pathetic for brian austin green yeah
even though like he was mean to her and
like j.lo
was cheated on by a-rod right so like i
don't really feel that bad for you but
like when someone's winning
publicly so hard i actually can't help
but feel bad for the other person even
if they were wrong in their relationship
do you know what i'm saying
i do know what you're saying i don't
feel bad yet no but i feel like it's
just getting good the daily mail like
had this picture of him like you know
his arms were crossed over his chest he
was going down this like big inflatable
slide
and it was just like it's lonely at the
top like you could have the biggest
yacht
in the bay but you're alone and like
it's sad it's lonely at the
top of the slide
it's lonely at the top of the inflatable
slide for sure and he is like the
biggest i can't i need to see that
picture
it's pathetic like it really is so like
i'm sorry i'm human
i'm starting to feel bad for him i'm not
there yet i'm just really enjoying this
moment because i do feel like i didn't
allow myself to get excited about all
the previous moments
because i just felt like it could still
be speculation somehow but here's the
two of them getting in and out of the
same range rover like wasn't enough for
me but like last week they were shopping
for houses together like
like he was just maybe they were like
about to go into like an investment
together like still
i just like you're so you're so scared
of being like presumptuous that you
become like a conspiracy theorist you
don't want to get hurt
that's fair that's actually something i
also feel like so many times with these
with couples like we jump to conclusions
yeah and that's how i wind up like
building ships that
[ __ ] sink yeah so not like a-rods
not like a-rods ship oh it's huge
yeah but so is the titanic at the top of
the slide
so i'm really happy for you know it's
just tough it's always like
when i mean i've only had one boyfriend
so i've never been there but i imagine
for other people like
when someone you were with gets back
with someone they were like with
previously because it was like was it
always about that right
how's anna de armas feeling right or
like
or right like for both of them on both
sides totally how's jennifer garner
feeling
not well oh that's not well because she
came right after her and she thought
that she was the one
i mean i actually feel like jennifer
gardner could not care less because no i
didn't
she was tortured by him for so long he
was in such a bad place like he was so
unwell
and she like got a boyfriend and got
engaged and like he's hot he's a
businessman but
i'm sure she's just like happy to be
it's all looks so fun when you're
watching pictures on the daily mail on a
yacht
but like at home happy to be rid of him
you think and his problems for sure
i don't think so i just feel like
there's a part of her that's like
extremely um
insecure no i don't want to say like
serious like serious isn't the word
competitive's not the word but just like
i feel the word competitive and i feel
the word serious where it's just like
in the so far the narrative up until
this point had been like
he left jlo literally like at the altar
and then found his true love in jennifer
garner they got married they
like and then and she was the one and it
was reminding me of and then everything
that came after was just like okay
like you know he's obviously in the
christmas lights yeah and now it's like
was jayla the one that got away it's
very cash trina and cinco
yes people who knew each other for three
weeks you know what i'm saying it's a
similar love triangle
yeah though i am behind yeah and that's
always like what i think like with
morgan stewart like the queen like a lot
of people don't know like her husband
now they used to date
yeah so now do you think like brendan is
like oh my god it was always jordan
because like it was always jordan 100
and it was and like you know you just
can't stop true love no you can't and
you shouldn't try
and that's why it's it'll always be
maverick that's why it'll
always be maverick um
did maverick see that episode with tyler
say do you think he was quaking no i
don't think he did
that's good better for his mental health
for sure are you ready for our next
story yeah
it's a little it's actually like a lot
of news that you know transpired over
the weekend
and um we got to talk about it kanye
west
is now living at atlanta stadium to
finish his album
donda so on friday or thursday night he
held a listening party
for donda at mercedes-benz stadium in
atlanta
kim was there the kids were there
everything was like so fabulous for me
personally
they were wearing matching outfits they
were wearing matching outfits and i
i'm not going to venture to say like
just i don't want to get my heart broken
i'm not going to say they're back
together because she was there but
they're on good terms and that means
everything to me yeah of course because
honestly like what i was really worried
about
was kim and kanye were good for each
other for a lot of reasons but for kim
like
he she was really his muse and i think a
lot we were talking about how like some
of her looks in rome were like a little
weird and like maybe she lost the kanye
fact but as long as i really want them
of course they'll always be in each
other's lives for co-parenting reasons
but i want them to still support each
other's art yeah and seeing her there
looking so sickening obviously styled by
kanye because they were both wearing
like the same shade of like kanye
yeezy gap red and like that just made me
feel relieved yeah i do feel relieved i
don't think he'll be styling her anymore
and i think i do feel like already
we're seeing the change in her style
based on the lack of his influence
not like i mean she always looks amazing
but she was always like on the complete
cutting edge of fashion with him
and now she's just like doing her own
thing whatever yeah but i just really
i'm glad to see it's not even of course
they're gonna co-parent for the kids but
it's like they're publicly supporting
each other
yes it's all good it's it's mostly good
yeah the album never came out right then
the album never came out are supposed to
come on on friday now it's coming out
august 6th
which i personally was feeling okay
about because i'm just feeling
overwhelmed
i agree content in general and i just
didn't have the bandwidth to like sit
down
with my earphones and listen to
a whole album i just couldn't i agree i
actually wasn't ready for it especially
not by monday like
with a review for the toaster yeah no
and this is so kanye and art takes time
and i'm i'm in no rush but it was like
an uh because he did the listening party
there were so many collabs jay-z is on
it which is just like
really interesting and something i think
we should talk about because as we know
they haven't been on good terms for a
while
and i don't know what the root of the
problem was but i always felt like
beyonce didn't like him
yeah i'm sure it is deeper than that
honestly um and also like jay's
kanye like wanted to borrow money man
when connie wasn't dead right and like
there was like a money stuff too which
is always icky right but i'm sure and
that's what we knew publicly i'm sure
there was so much privately that we
didn't know
but it's nice to see them back together
that's what everyone is talking about
this collab first one since
watch the throne right um and
i guess he needs to perfect the album
and now he's living in mercedes-benz
stadium
recording and finalizing the album yes i
read it on juan then like it got picked
up everywhere he basically just really
liked the vibe of the stadium
and he didn't leave and then i said now
he's like going to the event it was like
a concert or something and like i saw
him in the same outfit
yeah he was wearing during the listening
party that red outfit and like the
pantyhose on his head yeah he was
wearing it again
yeah so um i guess that's cool i just i
feel like
maybe it's like something about the
acoustics of the stadium maybe they go
in there when
maybe maybe he had his listening party
heard his song in a stadium for the
first time and it wasn't exactly what he
wanted it to be
and now he's workshopping everything
with that stadium acoustics
and that's why you won't need to see him
because i can imagine there's so many
more comfortable studio options
i mean i'm not personally going to even
attempt to understand the logic behind
like why kanye does what kanye does he's
an artist he's a free thinker
so i don't really i'm not craving
an explanation if that makes sense i'm
going with stadium acoustics that
actually sounds like a very
reasonable response right but i don't
know people do crazy things all the time
when they're artists you know
yeah i mean i know i do i'm constantly
creating constantly creating
you are so that's exciting august 6th
donda we'll see you there
i'm sure it's going to be awesome i know
the song from the we reported on it
before
when you were gone one of the songs was
in the beats by dre commercial with
shikari richardson sounded really good
and then there's clips like being put
out from the listening party and it
sounds great
right but that sounds like really good
action i want to listen like an album
form i haven't listened to any clips
from the party did you watch the beats
by dre commercial yes
he's done miracles on me
really good really good i'm really
excited i mean we have not gotten our
sheet music yet
so that's how we know the album isn't
coming that it's not ready speaking of
700 episodes that is definitely a career
high
i would say that's in the top 10 of all
700 episodes
was performing exclusively on sunday if
you guys are new here
what was the last album called jesus's
king i got an email like
on a monday night saying
hi this is stephanie what's her name at
yeezy.com
she sent us sheet music of a new kanye
song well it's old now it's called close
on sunday and she wanted us to perform
it she wanted to hear our take on it
and she sent us the sheet music and i
was like can i get an mp3 she was like
no
so we had to well jackie really did
because we took music theory growing up
jackie whipped out her keyboard we
performed it it's honestly on youtube
you should check it out
i pretty much watch that um once a day
oh i don't
it's so good i'm not thrilled with my
performance oh really me neither and
i've actually never been so nervous like
i was more nervous to do that
than i was to perform at the beacon
theater like i had the biggest pit i was
i was freaking out right i agree
i think that's more nerve-wracking yeah
also a highlight of um the toast for me
is when we performed your song on the
episode the day that it dropped
of course um the speaker died at but our
spirits didn't
and that was just the craziest thing
that's that's my favorite
toast moments ever top ten for all time
i agree
all the halloween episodes are in there
so that's how many halloweens have been
done for
kardashians jonas brothers royal family
oh because breath wasn't yeah it's a
three kanye
performing toast that's five and we have
to fill up the other five for our top
ten episodes i'm sure it'll come to us
while we're sitting here yeah because um
rascal flatts is definitely in there for
me oh
good stuff yeah mad good stuff um
may i yes because it's time for our next
story but i feel as though you have
something to say
i do that's that's why we're so good
together that's why we have 700 episodes
you're so intuitive thank you claudia
today's episode is sponsored by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours better help is not a crisis line
and it is not self-help it is
professional therapy done securely
online
the service is available for clients
worldwide where you can log into your
account anytime
and send a message to your therapist
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room again
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available
because they want you to start living a
happier life today so many people have
been using better help that they are
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states
visit betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast to join the over a million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional so again morning test
listeners
can get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
toast thank you so much for that our
next story is is extremely layered i'm
going to take it from the top
but lala ken is denying shading megan
fox for not attending
the movie premiere why she's lying
everyone here is lying
i agree that this doesn't feel 100
truthful so as you may or may not know
lala kent vanderpump rules her fiance
her husband
they got married no beyonce still oh my
god i can't keep up everyone's wedding
is getting postponed i know i know and
then they just do it and then it's right
and it's like a small backyard ceremony
forget about it but i do think it's
beyonce so her fiance randall is a movie
producer and
he sorry sorry it's okay ignore me um
movie producer he made a movie called
midnight in the switch grass which films
like right before kovid
machine gun kelly is in it megan fox is
in it that is where they spread it oh
yeah bruce willis but this is so not
about oh that's where they met and
apparently emil hirsch also says on the
poster
um and that's where machine gun kelly
and megan fox met very exciting i think
megan fox is a star because she's
technically on the poster and michigan
kelly it's a small bit for him but
whatever they meant and it's
and it's good and so you would think
they would like highly regard this movie
right just because it's where they met
but the movie just came out and they
were not at the premiere they said that
you know with coveted cases spiking in
california they just
did not feel safe and then lala posted a
photo to her instagram story of her at
the premiere in front of the poster her
body is covering megan fox
and her caption is kind of uh covering
megan fox's name in the poster
and people were thinking that is because
she's like mad at megan for not
promoting this movie that rand made and
that megan
yeah of course and then i think i saw a
tweet and i don't know if it was fake
but it was machine gun being like why
would i go promote a movie i was in for
five minutes
right but and then also there's an old
instagram live clip that's
floating around now where machine and
megan are
like just going live and talking about
stuff and then they said like that they
pretty if they're in a movie like
they'll pretty much you know they're
just like acting in a movie he's like
except for the one and they were like
laughing about god
well this makes me sad because they've
been on lala and randall's podcast so i
thought they were for sure like two
power couples like loving each other up
but
it appears as though that is not the
case no i mean maybe it started out as
the case but then maybe
you know maybe they watch the movie and
they just like weren't feeling proud of
it
well i have to say randall isn't known
for making
good movies like mostly all of them are
actually bad not all of them no not
they're all like incredibly low rated on
rotten tomatoes yeah but except for like
the one
the survivor oh is that did he do that
yeah okay well the john travolta one god
was meant to be good yeah but it's like
literally one of the lowest rated movies
on rotten tomatoes in history right but
i
i feel like they had every intention of
it being a good film well i don't think
people set out to make badges
sometimes you're like this is just like
corny direct to dvd like yeah you know
what we're doing here
yeah yeah that's even sadder
yeah so this actually makes me really
sad because of course lala's shading her
and to pretending she's not like just
own it right so now
i feel like maybe this this whole drama
got like really messy and like
no one in the movie i'm sure bruce
willis is like get me out of this no
pictures and all of the stuff
bruce willis being dragged into this
drama is so embarrassing yeah well so
lala said my mom quickly took a picture
of me i was just standing next to the
poster
she said pose i want to get a picture i
quickly um
she said she was excited for the movie
and posted it and then went in to watch
the film
so she's saying there was no shade it
was just like an accident
i mean that's possible but there's more
evidence to support that it was
completely shady but there's so much
space on top of the poster for her to
put her caption it's so intentional
it's so intentional and if you look at
the photo you don't see anything wrong
with it but then if you look at what the
movie poster actually looks like it's
incredibly
intentional yeah but maybe she just
wants to clean up this mess because
nobody's associated with the movie wants
to deal with it yeah no and it's this is
also just like really shining a light on
how lame this movie was because if they
all
just went to the premiere would have
been like oh a movie i'm not gonna see
but now it's like well why not cause the
movie was bad and it's just like really
making an
emphasis on the fact that randall made
another bad movie i don't know i feel
like ultimately it would probably
lead to more eyeballs if everyone went
to the premiere we'd just see pictures
and be like okay that movie they were in
but now it's like
how bad it could be how bad could it be
let me watch
this is actually also an interesting
conversation because i was um on tick
tock and i saw like a bunch of different
celebrities talking about this
and i think kevin hart has gotten in
trouble for this like
if you're in a movie is it on you
to promote it because you're a part of
the film like you should want to promote
your project
or should you be paid by the studio to
promote it
what do you think because remember when
those sony emails got hacked
yes no i know exactly what you're
talking about kevin hart was like those
emails he got so much [ __ ] for it like
he wanted to be paid to promote his
movie
because that's his his time okay here's
what i think i don't
but who cares what i think but this is
what i think i care a lot if you're in a
movie
you should have to go to the premiere
yeah of course as far as posting on your
social channels you should be able to
work that into your deal for payment
especially if like you have a really big
following and that's probably why they
wanted you in the movie to begin with
right but then also a lot of people um
feel like if kevin hart didn't go to the
premiere of his own movie that he was
starring in he's on the post rob i'd be
like
oh i would also just be like why were
you in the movie if you don't want to be
a part of the movie
yeah and a lot of the bigger celebrity
that you get
a lot of times you take like a small
salary up front and then you get a huge
piece of the movie and that's how like
julia roberts made all of her money
she was like the first celebrity to
really do it so in that case you should
want to be on every red carpet because
the more successful the movie is the
more money that you make it's not like a
guarantee
right so i just thought it was
interesting um
it is interesting and i do think that
there is definitely
there's definitely beef here yeah well
the video that i was watching
was um about the movie precious
monique said she only got paid 50 000 to
do that movie and then they wanted her
to fly to can
and she was like are you kidding me yeah
she was like no pay me they're like
we'll give you a hotel room and a suite
and she was like
no was this unrelated to this you just
saw that separately or you saw that
separately but it is a conversation in
hollywood like should celebrities
have to be paid to promote their own
movies or should it just be a part of
their job
i think it depends on what we're talking
about in terms of promoting like this
premiere was in la they live in l.a like
they should have went but but
if you want someone to go to can like
your you better fly them to can put them
up hundred percent
yeah okay you ready for our next story
i guess it's it's some fancy royal
adjacent wedding news
f-r-a-j-n yeah was that right jesse
royal adjacent
no no jay
kitty spencer marries billionaire
michael lewis
so princess diana's 30 year old niece
lady kitty spencer who you might be like
what who why
she went viral at um the wedding of
of harry and megan i think she did yeah
that's how she got all of her instagram
followers because she went to the
wedding of
like a royal wedding and she was so
stunning and sickening that everyone was
like who was this girl
i just think it's worth mentioning um
like i knew her before and no you found
out like i don't think you realize
that's how you
discovered her because that's how you
discovered her are you ready
ladykittyspencer follows me on instagram
so i followed her back so i knew her
before everyone else only followed her
back once you knew who she was which was
from the wedding
yeah i'm telling you no i don't because
simon knows her
simon was at the wedding someone's
posting those premium pictures simon is
so cool
at the wedding i saw it she's so cool he
said so many people have amazing love
stories but he loves kitties and
michael's the most i don't know that was
really kind
of why princess diana's 30 year old
niece
lady kitty spencer has married a 62 year
old billionaire michael lewis
jealous the pair exchanged vows at villa
aldo in rome on sunday with the bride
wearing a gown by dolce gabbana a
designer she has modeled for since 2017
the sun reported
if you follow her on instagram like we
both do like she's always posting dolce
bulgaria she's just like
yeah she's like the fashion it girl of
london like every brand wants to work
with her so i'm sure there was literally
a million designers clamoring to
make her wedding dress which is like
such a crazy feeling and i saw a lot of
like mixed reviews about her dress
i thought it was stunning i didn't see
any reviews
but it was stunning spectacular
spectacular royal
classic traditional modern
everything never been done before but
it's traditional
yeah no it's like it's timeless it
really is like i feel like that photo
and like the royal wedding book
will age very well oh for sure this is a
dress that will age well it's just like
stunning visuals and
if you're interested in like royal
randomness
like this is she's a great follow yeah
no because she's like stunning she loves
this
it's literally a life nobody has it's so
outrageous like
and now she's a billionaire so like it's
only gonna go up from here
i really suggest following her on
instagram she's cousins with william and
harry
yeah but i feel like she doesn't like
they don't like associate with each
other no except for the wedding where
she went which went viral right right
right
right yeah and harry wasn't at the
wedding so like just lady
neither was william well of course not
does princess
that's actually kind of weird like why
would they go to their sister's a
cousin's wedding
i don't know in italy cobain yeah maybe
small well here's my question maybe they
hate each other
for sure um what was what was my
question
my question was such we were talking
about them being cousins
yeah i don't remember but a lot of
people oh yes
so of course kitty is like famous for
being diana's niece but also being
everything of the sort
i think she's mostly famous for being
everything of the sort and then her fame
was cinched by the fact that she's
diana's knees because
diana have other nieces i'm sure diana
has other nieces and i'm pretty sure
kitty has sisters
yeah or like brothers like a nephews of
diana yeah but they're not kitty because
right
so i was like is she special or she just
the only last remaining niece
she's special she is okay for sure that
was my question and then my other thing
was a lot of people are also clapped at
like she's 30 he's 62 but he's a
millionaire so
age doesn't matter simon said it's his
favorite love story yeah so it's
obviously something
we just marketed as a trustworthy guy no
totally and simon was posting the most
premium pics because i was like at surf
lodge like wasted this weekend i'm like
where are you he's like i'm in rome
i'm like oh man you're going to a royal
wedding and i'm eating chicken fingers
at surf lodge
honestly i think i would prefer to have
been at starbucks everyone has their own
journey
100
so um also just a fun fact about for any
redheads readers out there
lady kitty spencer the spencer household
diana spencer as well it's part of
spencer churchill household which
is the family that consuelo vanderbilt
married into and they reside at blenheim
palace
blenheim palace which the blenheim pups
are named after it's really
just a beautiful full circle so
kitty's mom is diana's sister dad
oh okay brother because whatever
happened because in the crown
william the sister charles came over to
date diana's sister and diana slithered
in there and stole him yeah
what happened to that girl i don't know
is she alive
i'm sure is she but she's not related to
kitty through blood
she is kitty's auntie they're marriage
no diana has a younger brother
that's kitty's dad
got it got it got it got it oh that's
why she spencer well that also
definitely helps
yeah yeah yeah very interesting
well wishing her and her rich husband
all the best
all the best you guys should check out
her instagram and check out her look
because it was
quite sickening also i'm um looking
forward to the honeymoon content i feel
like it'll be really good
private jets i feel like they're going
to go to san jose everyone's in santa
bay
i know but i feel like she doesn't post
like iphone photos it's only like if
someone's shooting her
like a bulgari photo shoot right and
it's always a babari photo shoot
always and honestly i relate to her like
it's so hard to have to do so many photo
shoots for so many designers like
this one brand shot morning toast like
they don't stop taking photos of me it's
so annoying
i can't shop morning toast is going to
design your wedding dress
literally it's going to be a crew neck
dress
with a tmt patch on the breasts
[Laughter]
please make a graphic of like what a
crew neck dress would look like on a
body like just take one of my wedding
pictures i'm actually so curious
because that would be so funny a crew
neck dress that is so funny
honestly if i could read you my wedding
i would [ __ ] do it or at my after
party dress would just be an oversized
kernick in white yeah tmt on the side
it's so cute so cute are you ready for
our fifth and final story oh my god
already
already time flies when it's your 700
episode
i know um but is today's fifth story
brought to you by bowling branch or not
should i just
should i just go should you send it back
send it back again no no it is
thank you god okay well bowling branch
is everything of the sort and that's
really much
really all you need to know but if you
are looking for uncompromising comfort
with the best-selling 100 organic cotton
signature hem sheets then you got to
check out bowlin branch we both switched
to wollon ranch like
a long time ago now maybe like eight
months and i've never looked back yeah
breathable
cotton i'm a very warm sleeper it's very
i sometimes
feel like i'm being suffocated when i
sleep but bowling branch is so
lightweight but it also keeps you warm
but it also keeps you cool it's like a
magic technology
um they're dedicated to quality at every
step over at bowling branch their sheets
are designed and manufactured
for maximum comfort and durability and
they don't cut any quarters because
there's no middlemen
between you and bowling branch you're
getting luxury quality for the fairest
price
and they stand behind their products and
they honor a 30-night worry-free
guarantee
so if you're not satisfied which i can't
imagine that you wouldn't be satisfied
you can get your money back
send it back no problem it is the
perfect balance of weight
and breathability to pamper warm or cool
sleepers throughout any season
give your bed the white house treatment
with sheets that three presidents have
fallen in love with how interesting is
that
um their manufacturing partners are
family-owned businesses that share the
same values and standards
so you can feel good knowing that you
are sleeping on something made ethically
and also that's keeping you fabulously
asleep
so to experience an entirely new
standard of comfort visit
and if you want to get 15 off your first
set of sheets use the promo code toast
that's b-o-l-l and branch dot com
bowlin branch dot com promo code toast
for
10 15 off excuse me thank you for that
yeah it was a pleasure and an honor
as always and now for the fifth and
final story which is some exciting
tnn adjacent news which is that raven
and adam are pregnant with a little
bebe she says i've wanted to be a mom
for a long time
it's been nearly four months since raven
and adam tie the knot and now their
family is expecting
she said it's so exciting we found out
right after the wedding i've wanted to
be a mom for a long time and i always
imagined
creating a family with someone i love so
much and expanding my love with adam
into a human i can't even imagine
they conceived on their honeymoon so
this is a honeymoon
and they are expecting in january
they're such a fabulous couple
beyond fabulous i'm really happy for
them they found love in a hopeless place
bachelor paradise
they really did and i feel like we
forget like when we think about the
successful
couples of bachelor nation i always
forget about them because they met on
paradise and they're just so low-key
like they just moved to dallas and live
their [ __ ] lives
and i think we knew that this was coming
she said on her podcast girls night
which
um was date night with her and adam they
wanted to take a step back they were
thinking of starting a family so
i'm really happy for them it was premium
content and she's she's really like the
sweetest girl
she is and i'm so happy for them i'm
really happy for them the content was
very premium the pictures were sickening
and
i'm happy for the gotcha gates family
also speaking of bachelor nation i am on
jason tardik's podcast today
i saw i recorded it a long time ago and
i was kind of nervous to do it because
it's all about like money
and i'm like weird i mean i think like a
lot of people are yeah like when talking
about money or like business
but i actually really liked it i think
it's a really great idea for a podcast
it's all about like
it's called trading secrets so like
you're trading secrets with someone from
different industries
and just all that like how you make
money and how you sustain life as an
influencer
and i had a really good time so if you
want to check that out you should do
that you should definitely check that
out definitely 100
so that's it like are we going to wrap
up that's our 700 700
anything you want to say i was just
going to ask you the same i don't know
just feeling grateful
excited about the future grateful for
the past
so many memories yeah i don't know if
i'm like grateful for the past
it but it made you the woman that you
are it did constantly looking today
constantly looking forward anything that
you want to change for 701 plus
that's a good question i mean we
recently did our podcast reviews
so i feel like i got a lot of
constructive criticism yeah um
and so moving forward i'm gonna
constantly um just
try to keep my talking to a normal pace
mm-hmm i'm going
to a complaint it wasn't fast talking
now
it should be i listened to the episode
i'm like what the [ __ ] are these hookers
saying like i have no idea what they're
saying
um so i'm gonna work on that i'm
definitely gonna try and sing more
more than ever actually working on new
music i think that that was the feedback
that we received most was policing more
yeah no and it was like overwhelming and
really humbling because you know my
troop
like i love what we do here but you know
if i could have any job in the world i
would want to be like a
famous pop star yeah um and so for
people just to kind of like see that in
us was so humbling right we didn't sing
once today
not even for 700. not even oh not even
for the final story
i know like the triangles where are they
wait we okay so a couple before you left
like maybe two weeks ago
we were getting really into our final
story song which if you don't know it
goes a little something like this
it's the final story and we were
you were saying how we really need like
a percussion the note that we
end on would sound beautiful with a
triangle so i think that we should end
the show
with a rendition of final story but i
think we should try and find a way to
say
it's a 700 yeah the only thing is that
we can't find the triangles where did i
put them that's a great question excited
i know i feel like they're on the
shelves they're in like
i put wait i put them all in like one
thing of course like i never know where
i put anything
just you hold down the ford i'll be
right back okay and then will you get
into your head
it's the 7th hundredth i keep saying
700th but it's 700th with ben affleck
nice she found them we are in business
wow those are so cute they're amazon's
finest instruments
okay brand new this one was mine that
one's yours because i opened this one
okay and that's my tapper yeah take it
out of the thing
and asmr which side do you think we hit
it with the rubber or the
no uh i think rubber oh that's beautiful
okay rubber
and hold from the top yeah okay
it's the set oh what are we doing oh my
god sorry i wasn't listening to anything
you were saying before i was busy
looking for the
triangles it's the 700
700 sorry 8700
700. yes if you were listening to me you
would have known i was struggling with
okay
it's the 700.
it's not a drum sorry okay we just sing
normally and then the last note we do a
little ring
so only we bought these to play it once
once a day no okay you do the final one
i will improvise percussion wise it
sounded good
it was okay it lingers too it sounded
good i could stop it
it's the 700 700
700 700
700
[Music]
you're using the wrong side [ __ ] no
no but you have to like give it like a
it's more like does it only play one
note yeah oh that's a good question
no it should play different notes
is this annoying it's a one note it's a
whatever we gotta we should get like
some
nails and just hang it up here so for
easy access
that's our 700th show you guys you are
the best
thank you all so much for tuning in to
how
i feel like there's definitely one
person who's listened to all 700
right us
[Laughter]
well for anyone who's ever listened to
even one episode we love you guys thank
you so much
on to the next 700 am i right on to the
next 700.
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories every monday friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please definitely subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
where we've delivered the fast five
stories 700 times
700 times five is 3 500 correct 3 500
stores
that sounds right yeah 3 500 stories
of mindlessness 525
000. 3500 stories we're also available
as podcasts and where podcasts can be
found so it's spotify i can stitch your
public radio way ready
box all the places so when you listen to
podcasts find out it's more until the
five-star review about our beautiful
stunning and smart we are the society
season two
what emoji should we do today but in the
block numbers
of course the big blue seven blue with
the white seven yeah okay yeah number
seven bye guys we'll see you tomorrow
bye
you